I know you're originally from Canada yes
but you're living here in Los Angeles
and because you are Canadian you just
love hockey yes we love ha you have to
love hockey if you're from Canada it's
like a rule born with skates on yes very
painful very painful save money on a
cesarean hideous yeah
but then you always have to leave the
house through the window yeah you know
the point is we will get to the point
here yes let's say you adopted the you
said I'm here in LA I'm living here and
you started watching the LA Kings and
you became not just a fan you became a
huge fan of the LA Kings I did i I've
been a fan since I've you know the 70s
have been a fan of the Kings and and
then last year of course they won the
whole thing and I and I even went I
traveled you know I even went to some of
the road games and when they they were
in the finals against New Jersey and I
had the I had the lovely experience of
being shown on the jumbotron in New
Jersey in New Jersey and being booed by
20,000 people they booed you yes it's so
weird you're such a popular guy but I
guess they know that you're rooting for
the other team yes they had seen me you
know rooting for the Kings all the way
through and they and they showed me on
the jumbotron and and 20,000 people
booed me and it's a it's a terrible
feeling yes
oh I know even though you know why it's
happening it's still a terrible feeling
and the worst part of it was they didn't
show a live shot of me on the jumbotron
it was a shot from like 10 minutes
earlier so I couldn't even you know be
sheepish about I couldn't even go like
right you know yeah so it looked like I
was on the jumbotron being booed by
20,000 people and this was my expression
[Laughter]
[Applause]
ridiculous and it happened to be game 5
is a game that they that the Kings lost
and as I was trying to get to my car it
just took forever like 200-300 people
asked for my autograph and the picture
and I was like you guys just booed me
and they all said well I didn't like
sure you didn't yeah now since you are
such a big fan and you become close with
the team did you get a chance to look at
the Stanley Cup person did you get to go
and visit it it was great it was on say
Kopitar who's their leading scorer I had
become kind of friendly with him during
the during the run of the Cup and when
you win the Stanley Cup you get a day
with the Stanley Cup
all the players give it one day what
I've heard about yes legendary yeah yeah
and so he called me up and he said my
day is you know next Saturday and I'm
gonna have a party and where he lives
and I said you know you know let me
throw you a party at my house and I sent
him like my house has a nice view
because you know I was on friends
I bet you used that line a lot in your
life I'll have the really good steak
because I was on Frasier well we're
gonna split the bill because I was also
on mr. sunshine so I sent him a picture
of the view from my house and he said
yeah let's have it at your house so you
brought he brought the Stanley Cup to
your house yes and I believe we have a
picture here of the Stanley Cup admiring
the view at your house yeah Wow
that's fantastic so that's that's the
Stanley Cup at my house yeah and auntie
Kopitar brought it over there and the
only problem with that is now when I
show a picture of my house subsequent to
that night it looks like crap because no
it does because there's no there's no
Stanley Cup I was looking at that and
figuring out exactly where you live
that's what I was doing I'm hoping
you're the hope I got it I got it yeah
the only one who did that no no I think
we were all like yeah oh yeah oh yeah I
could get to that Bush oh yeah yeah I'm
good
he likes throwing parties